Das ist das Schloss von Versailles hunderte Angestellte,
extravagante Feste, Hallen aus Gold und ein riesiger Park mit eigenen Kanälen.
Ein Leben in Luxus und Reichtum das nur den obersten 0,001 Prozent der Gesellschaft vorbehalten war
und vielleicht bald auch dir oder mir.
Nehmen wir mal an Buddhisten und Hindus haben recht und so etwas ähnliches wie Reinkarnation
gibt es wirklich, das heißt nachdem du stirbst wirst du wiedergeboren.
Zu einer anderen Zeit und an einem anderen Ort und zu deinem Glück kannst du dir sogar aussuchen
wohin ist dich in deinem neuen Leben verschlagen soll.
In unseren Gedankenexperiment hast du zwei Möglichkeiten:
erstens du wirst wiedergeboren als Kind einer normalen mittelständischen Familie im Jahr 2000
oder Option 2 du wirst wiedergeboren im Jahr 1710 als der französische Thronfolger Ludwig XV.
Wofür entscheidest du dich?
Als Thronfolger kannst du dich von einer normalen Wohnung verabschieden, denn ab jetzt gehört dir ein ganzer Palast.
Neben einem Zimmer nur für deine Hunde und einem weiteren Zimmer nur für deine Uhren,
stehen knapp 2000 Bedienstete nur in den Küchen des Palastes bereit. Jetzt bist du am obersten ende der Nahrungskette!
Wortwörtlich! Jeder Wunsch wird dir von deinen Lippen abgelesen. Dir muss nie wieder langweilig sein.
Du veranstaltet gigantische Feste. Tage lang!
Geld ist kein Problem. Geht es dann zum Ernst des Lebens zurück, dann stehen hier die besten Bildungsmöglichkeiten des Landes zur Verfügung.
Du hast die Möglichkeit dich von den klügsten Köpfen des 18. Jahrhunderts unterrichten zu lassen.
Rousseau, Diderot oder Voltaire. Mit einem Fingerschnipsen sitzen ein paar der größten Philosophen aller Zeiten in deinem Palast und erklären dir die Welt.
Ist es dann Zeit deinen Thron anzutreten, hast du die Macht und Ressourcen um die Welt zu verändern.
Heutzutage besitzt wahrscheinlich kein Mensch weltweit die macht, die du jetzt hast. Du reagierst schließlich Frankreich.
Kolonialmacht und als der größten europäischen Königreiche.
Politisch sieht das für dich auch relativ entspannt aus. Das 18. Jahrhundert hatte zwar ein, zwei kleine Kriege. Ja!
Verlierst Kanada als Kolonie, aber sonst hält dich nichts davon ab "off the side" zu  Faulenzen. Oder?
Moment mal da war doch irgendwas?
Ok! Also spätestens 1789 wird sich die Welt für dich ein kleines Bisschen verändern,
Denn dein Luxus hat einen Preis der auf den Schultern von armen Bauern getragen wird.
Aber vielleicht hast du ja Glück. Denn damit du die Französische Revolution überhaupt erlebst,
musst du nämlich erst einmal 79 Jahre alt werden
und König Ludwig XV. hat gerade mal von 1710 bis 1774 überlebt.
Denn Pocken, Tuberkulose oder andere Plagen machen vor einem Blauen Blut nicht halt
und das Gesundheitswesen im 18. Jahrhundert ist naja sagen wir mal ausbaufähig.
OK! Dafür hattest du aber Jahrzehnte voller Saus und Braus. Oder?
Leider wirst du selbst als zukünftiger König oder als Königin nicht so viele Freiheiten haben wie teilweise heutzutage.
Besonders als Frau sieht das 18. Jahrhundert nicht so rosig für dich aus.
Patriarchale Strukturen, Zwangsheirat mit deinen adligen Verwandten. Dein Leben ist komplett durchgeplant, sodass du für den Erhalt des Stammbaums sorgst.
Hinzu kommt dass hunderttausende Bauern am Existenzminimum leben damit du mit goldenen Besteck essen kannst.
"Sollen die bauern halt Kuchen essen wenn sie kein Brot haben!" Oder wie war das nochmal?
Naja! Da hat selbst das leckerste Festessen einen faden Beigeschmack.
OK! So wie sich das jetzt anhört ist das also eine ziemlich einfache Entscheidung. Viele dieser Probleme sind gelöst, wenn du dich für die Gegenwart entscheidest.
Klar du bist dann mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit ein ganz normaler Mensch ohne Reichtum und Macht,
aber dafür profitierst du von modernster Medizin und hat die Freiheit dich selbst zu verwirklichen.
Du kannst überall hinreisen wo du willst. Du bist mobiler und flexibler, als eine der mächtigsten Personen vor gerade mal 300 Jahren!
An dieser Stelle dürfen wir auch nicht den technischen Fortschritt vergessen!
Auf Schloss Versailles läuft kein Netflix. Du kannst nicht mal eben ein Smartphone checken während du auf die Kutsche wartest
und das Plumpsklo brauchen wir gar nicht erst gegen ein modernes bad antreten zu lassen.
Diesen Fortschritt würdest du im 18. Jahrhundert aber natürlich nicht wirklich "vermissen".
Denn diese zeit ist eine neue Realität. Schließlich vermissen wir jetzt gerade ja auch nicht die Technologien aus der Zukunft.
Trotzdem stehen wir in der Gegenwart auf den Schultern von hunderten Jahren an Fortschritt,
die unsere Realität um einiges einfacher machen als noch vor 300 Jahren.
Dieser Fortschritt hat aber auch seinen preis!
Klimawandel, Massenvernichtungswaffen und die Ausbeutung günstiger Arbeitskräfte.
Ganz so dramatisch wie im Feudalismus ist das natürlich nicht,
trotzdem werden auch in der Gegenwart große Opfer für den Konsum der oberen paar Prozent gebracht.
Und weltweit gesehen sind wir die oberen paar Prozent. Wir sind die Könige des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Wie würde deine Antwort zum Beispiel aussehen wenn du heute überall auf der ganzen Welt geboren werden könntest?
Je nach deinem Geburtsort hast du auch in der Gegenwart so gut wie keine Mobilität.
Leidest unter Armut und Krieg, profitiert nicht vom Fortschritt der Menschheit
und hast so gut wie keine Möglichkeit dein Schicksal selbst zu gestalten.
Das kann dir auch passieren, wenn du in Deutschland geboren wirst.
Als französischer König hast du das Geld und die Macht, um das 18. Jahrhundert zu einem fairen Ort zu machen.
Chancengleichheit für alle. Die Industrialisierung steht noch vor der Tür!
Du könntest den weg ebnen für eine nachhaltige Zukunft und so maßgeblich die Weltgeschichte verändern.
Das setzt natürlich voraus dass überhaupt das Interesse entwickelst zumindest Frankreich zu einem besseren Ort zu machen.
Denn du würdest die gleiche Bildung Sozialisierung und Politisierung wie ein vergleichbarer Monarch zu dieser Zeit bekommen.
und da stehen Chancengleichheit Fairness und Ethik nicht gerade ganz oben auf der Agenda
und realistisch gesehen wird es ganz schön hart sein jahrhundertealte Machtstrukturen einfach so umzuwerfen.
Denn allein in Frankreich gibt es neben dir genug Leute die von den feudalen Strukturen profitieren
und überhaupt kein Interesse haben, ihre Privilegien zu verlieren.
Auch andere Königreiche werden nicht sehr begeistert sein wenn du das traditionelle System umwirfst.
Es wurden schon Kriege wegen kleineren Problemen angefangen!
Und vielleicht kommst du ja gar nicht so weit. vielleicht steigt der deine macht sogar zu Kopf.
du wärst nicht der erste König der verrückt wird.
König Karl VI. dachte Zeit seines Lebens das er aus Glas wäre und hat deswegen tagelang still gesessen um nicht kaputt zu gehen.
Lassen wir das materielle das gesellschaftliche und das politische mal außen vor:
Das lebenswerteste Leben ist das in dem du am glücklichsten bist und was Glück bedeutet das muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden.
falls ihr euch für die Wissenschaft hinter Glück interessiert, dann schaut euch gerne mal dieses Video von mir zu diesem Thema an.
Orientieren wir uns an den Menschenrechten dann kann man ein paar fundamentalen Voraussetzungen für ein glückliches leben definieren:
platonische und nicht platonische Beziehungen zu verschiedenen Menschen, Komfort also eine gute Versorgung an Sicherheit und Nahrung und
Anerkennung und Respekt durch Mitmenschen.
Dieses glück kannst du sowohl als Thronfolger aber auch als normaler Bürger erreichen.
Mit einem kleinen Unterschied: in der Gegenwart braucht es für deine Sicherheit und Komfort Arbeit und Geld. Das sind zwei Dinge um die sich ein Thronfolger keine Gedanken machen muss.
in der Gegenwart lebst du in der Leistungsgesellschaft.
Schon früh musst du dich entscheiden welchen Bildungsweg du einschlägst, um später vielleicht mal eine Familie ernähren zu können.
Dabei stehen die unfassbar viele Möglichkeiten zur Verfügung.
Für viele Menschen ist das Fluch und Segen zugleich.
Unsere eigene Identität und Rolle in der Gesellschaft zu finden ist vielleicht so schwierig wie noch nie zuvor in der Geschichte der Menschheit.
Quaterlifecrisis, Midlifecrisis, Altersarmut.
Für viele menschen sorgt die Leistungsgesellschaft für enormen Druck.
als Thronfolger sind deine Grundbedürfnisse für dein ganzes leben befriedigt
und manch einer ist vielleicht auch ganz froh dass das eigene Leben im 18. Jahrhundert nach einem gewissen Plan verläuft.
Vielleicht brauchen wir aber auch das moderne Streben nach Glück um uns glücklich zu fühlen.
Wenn du von vorneherein alles besitzt was du jemals besitzen kannst wird man dann nicht unglücklich?
OK jetzt würde mich mal eure Meinung interessieren für welches Leben würdet ihr euch entscheiden schreibt mir gerne unten in die Kommentare
und lasst uns zusammen darüber diskutieren.
Wenn ihr kein kommendes Video verpassen wollt, dann abonniert gerne den Kanal da unten das ist kostenlos.
Ansonsten wie immer vielen dank fürs Zuschauen bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bleibt neugierig! euer König Cedrick der fünfte... ach was sage ich da Cedric reicht